hello everyone we're here at cube con
Barcelona with Bryan Liles Bryan is
senior staff engineer at VMware and also
the co-chair of cube con Bryan can you
talk to us a little bit about what that
role is and what what it involves
so the co-chairs we plan this whole
entire conference sans the vendor stuff
so all of the all the sessions all the
keynotes we coordinate the people who do
the reviews we make the final reviews we
create the schedules we get everybody in
line as you know we sit down with our
keynote speakers and we help them make
better talks everything you see the
conference that makes you happy
we had a hand in it most likely that's
awesome so how did you get involved with
this and why did you think that this was
something that you really wanted to do
CN CF contacted me last year I had
already done work with Linux Foundation
helping planning the OS summit for a
while and I think that they saw that I
was good on stage and I was able to do
planning for conferences it was actually
a good fit for a position that opened up
late last year in terms of how you've
seen cube con evolve over time and
what's different at this cube con what
do you what do you see so one thing we
highlight this morning there are seventy
seven hundred people here this is
literally the biggest open-source
conference in Europe and when we do our
next one in the United States it'll be
the biggest open-source conference in
the world
that's comes very far from whenever we
met in San Francisco and then when we
did Berlin how do you make sure that
this is happening in a sustainable way
it's all about the open source not about
your company you know you work at Google
I work at VMware but you notice that
we're not selling anything we're
basically talking about the benefits of
the open source community really what
this conference is about is showing what
everyone has to offer
offering open source content to our
people and making sure that it's just
not a self s this is not a vendor event
so it sounds like the future is moving
beyond kubernetes and figuring out what
we can do with the building blocks that
kubernetes is offered
yeah I think that's actually it I'm
kubernetes was never supposed to be
end-all be-all it's basically you know
it's computing networking storage
everything else needs to be provided
outside and I'm I'll speak for VMware in
a little bit because you know we've been
doing this literally for twenty years
now
you know this basically the
software-defined data center what we're
seeing is now that I'm growing in this
cloud native ways it just opens up so
much space and then you know looking at
what Google did you know Google starts
in the ad space and then you know got
really good at compute but now you're
seeing that we all need to move in a
different direction because
unfortunately you know none of us have
cracked this not yet and that's great
that's amazing that means we're making
progress and we haven't stagnated yet so
one of the really cool things I've seen
at the conference was the mental health
session I think it was born out of the
realization that folks are starting to
burn out in the community can you talk a
little bit about that when we did
Seattle back in December we have we
always have a retrospective session it's
like really the last session the last
day anyone who wants to come there's a
lot of sentiment cinnamon in that room
where you know this is hard and you know
you want to go to all the talks and you
want us to meet all the people and you
know we're humans and we can't handle
that so we always were paying attention
to it but Sheryl hung who works with CN
CF she actually wanted the extra stuff
and they coordinated with people that
they could actually have in booth
downstairs in the sponsor showcase that
you could talk to if you get burnt out
but I also want to encourage anyone if
you think about this a conference is
just that it's a conference and there's
gonna be there's gonna be hallway track
there's keynotes there's tutorials and
then there's you know there's general
sessions the best thing about a
conference like this is generally almost
everything is recorded so last question
what are you looking forward to at cube
con um so this year what I'm looking
forward to is there's a lot of software
being announced and people talking about
these projects that go above and beyond
so what I'm looking for is something
that I didn't expect and you know it's
kind of weird to say but you know we go
through these talks and you're like
someone's gonna talk about service [ __ ]
all right
talk about I want someone to go further
than that and maybe take the service
mesh or anything else even further than
it is or even storage further than it is
now that's what I'm looking for I'm
looking for the things that will
probably hit you know hit main line in
the next year but I want to hear about
it now so I can start following along
awesome thank you very much Brian laughs
[Music]